thank you ted after a year hiatus the
sponsors of this segment great american
foodie fest is back and i couldn't wait
to stop by and check it out earlier
today to give you guys a preview take a
look
it's a very exciting news foodie fest is
back after a one year hiatus and the man
behind it all this is noelle the founder
of the creator of it all how many food
trucks we got out there this year we
have about 30 food trucks and about 20
food vendors this year it's big we
missed you guys last year how does it
feel to be back this year well after
three castle events and and two years of
doing nothing it's it's it's amazing to
be back it hasn't even started because
the doors open at five but i already
feel like a food energy and a festival
energy going on let's walk around here
so the doors open at five how much is it
to get in
so it's seven dollars pre-sale they go
right now before five o'clock okay after
that at the gates ten dollars to get in
so jump online right now get your
tickets in advance it's not only just
great food that you guys have but
there's also great carnival rides
where's some of the rides we have here
this year we have some amazing rides
there we have the kamikaze we have the
zipper we have the ferris wheel we have
we actually have a new new uh carnival
this year the car that we used last year
went out of business so this is an
awesome carnival that we came across
though the gallery at sunset as i'm
pulling up that's the first thing i see
it's a gigantic beers wheel and i'm
walking up here i start hearing the
carnival rides going on it's a festival
uh event tonight perfect for the entire
family something you're bringing back
this year and a lot of people are
excited about no more cashless systems
no more casters i'm glad you mentioned
that because a lot of people complained
about that
no more magic money is what we use this
is called magic money no more and so uh
also too um are there eating contests
happening this weekend we always have
eating contests every year absolutely
what are some of the contents did you
guys do uh hot beef jerky contest egg
roll contest is a mobile contest let's
let's uh yeah sorry you're busy man you
have calls coming what are some of the
uh some of the vendors that can be out
here this weekend what style of food are
we gonna have
well you name it we bring out some of
the best food trucks not only here
locally but some of the best food trucks
that have been featured on the food
network cooking channel travel channel
from all over the country brought to one
local destination that's the foodie fest
it's it's huge i missed you guys last
year um let's talk about parking um are
you guys charging for parking no no
charging
this is something for everyone it really
truly is a family event absolutely
absolutely yeah bring the family and the
kids and stuff you can win some prizes
you can eat lots of food uh oh is there
music here this year so we just have a
live dj this year due to coveted
restrictions we just wanted to keep it
simple
so no live bands but do you have music
you have a dj yeah absolutely so there's
gonna be entertainment out here tonight
and starts tonight five o'clock what are
the hours going this weekend so friday
five to 11 saturday 11 a.m to 11 p.m and
then sunday 11 a.m to 10 p.m as you
mentioned so many uh food trucks you
have out here in the carnival rides i
think you need to come out here more
than one day absolutely that's why you
buy one ticket it's good for all three
days are you serious all three days
unlimited re-entry i want to give the
website so the website is great
americanfoodiefest.com right you got it
jump on there now buy your tickets
advanced because they're only seven
dollars bye now no well thank you so
much buddy appreciate it thank you
brother come out to foodie fest you guys
thank you again to great american foodie
fest for sponsoring this segment the
festival starts tonight five o'clock and
lasts through the weekend it's out there
in henderson call them for more
information at 702-410-8565
as mentioned pre-sale tickets only seven
dollars ten dollars at the door great
american foodie fest.com that is a
worthy